soirée d'effervescence à bangui où est
présenté le premier long métrage de
centrafrique produits en coopération
avec la russie
ce film d'action retrace la contribution
de la russie à la stabilisation du pays
lors de l'élection présidentielle de
décembre dernier
même s'il s'agit d'une fiction elle se
veut fidèle au déroulé des événements
qui a permis aux forces centrafricaines
encadrés par des instructeurs russe de
repousser les assauts rebelles afin que
le scrutin puisse avoir lieu c'est
d'ailleurs le constat dressé par les
autorités centrafricaines qui jugent
positive la contribution de cette
contribution rsa lutter pour moi les
statuts ça l'était pourquoi elle est
salutaire passé et défend la population
aujourd'hui si on avait laissé s'il y
avait passé le cd des forces alliées
gong li doit être pour moi on va vous
voulez encore convives c'est que nous
avons vu qu en 2014 2015 2016
non en tout cas c'est pourquoi je suis
fier de me dire et j'ai parfois au sud
pour dire haut et fort que je soutiens
cette ses opérations et ses éléments qui
sont vraiment déterminés d'une zep qui
sont captés de nous dès qu'ils
continuent à nous aider l'ambassadeur
russe de son côté souligner les efforts
des instructeurs russe qui depuis
plusieurs années ont aidé à remettre sur
pied les forces armées centrafricaines
les sacs à 0,6 bien sûr la situation
s'est stabilisée dans une large mesure
et l'accord lui même a été possible
parce que nos instructeurs entraînent
leurs forces armées depuis 2018 et les
forces armées qui ont été le fait
complètement détruite lors de l'entrée
des routes du nord à bangui ont été
restaurées au tce constamment menés
quant aux accusations d'exactions
commises par certains de ses
instructeurs
elles sont trop vagues pour qu'on y
prête attention d'après cet observateur
avisé
nous faisons face à une situation où il
y à des experts
sans aucun doute ne sont jamais venus
ici personne ne dit quand il est venu
ici avec qui il a parlé
il dit simplement par exemple qu'un
russe où les forces armées
centrafricaines viol des femmes
cambriole des maisons commettent des
massacres et tortures des gens mais à
aucun moment je n'ai entendu de détail
10 a été torturé ou quel est le nom de
famille de sept personnes
la maison cambriolée où se trouve-t-elle
où se trouve la femme violée les
massacres et les enterrements ou ont-ils
eu lieu il n'y a rien de tout ça ce sont
des déclarations non fondées qui reste
extrêmement floue oignons la population
quant à elle constate que la paix est
globalement revenu et ne souhaite qu'une
chose qu'elle dure on a vu comment la
russie avec la contribution de l'art de
l'armée rwandaise
enfin le peuple centrafricains sont
satisfaits on a pu également souffert et
gras sol aux armées russes car on a pu y
aller à l'école
on a pu travailler l'appui fallu
cependant notre pays la pitié alors
messieurs les amis russes en
centrafrique
c'est une contribution positive à 16
vous l'arrestation stabilisation de
notre pays ce que nous voulons c'est là
et et c'est en voulant qu'une paire
durable ça lui fait du rapport aux neufs
a grimpé qu'elle veut même si la
situation reste encore fragile
le peuple centrafricain espère avoir mis
cette crise derrière lui et souhaite que
la paix s'installe durablement pour que
pour une fois en centrafrique
le film se termine